[Musique]
Guillaume Gallienne quelle idée vous
faites-vous de la France
un état nation c'est la première chose
qui me vient
depuis toujours presque
on est un pays uni
oui on est on n'est pas une fédération
on n'est pas on est un état de nation
vraiment
une entité très forte après qui se
décline de Vercingétorix c'est
aujourd'hui avec le coq avec Marianne
avec qui vous voulez mais c'est une
entité nation vraiment la
nationale
c'est une langue c'est une langue ou
l'accent tonique est quand même libre de
choix
l'accent tonique n'est pas inscrit dans
la langue et ça donne une
une liberté d'interprétation énorme ça
c'est une singularité française ah oui
ah oui oui on est une langue
d'interprétation plus que d'incarnation
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on a des
très belles voix on n'a pas tellement de
jolies corps dans notre cinéma ou dans
notre théâtre et alors c'est une langue
aussi qui peut varier avec la
francophonie c'est à dire que si elle
est parlée par un Québécois elle est
évidemment enrichi de notre histoire
colonialiste impérialiste tout ce que
vous voulez mais avec évidemment le
créole avec je pense à Dany Laferrière
évidemment mais
ah oui
et que ce soit en Afrique ou au Canada
oui bien sûr mais c'est une langue qui
sur une sur une ligne artienne le
français est très plat il a l'air très
plat il module assez peu on le module
peut on en fait c'est comme un fleuve
c'est c'est je crois que c'est
Mitterrand qui lors de sa défaite en 74
avait parlé du destin les journalistes
il y avait un article très méchant sur
lui il dit mine ça rien du destin est-ce
que le dessin de la de la scène c'était
de se jeter dans l'océan ou traverser
Paris et
il y a ça un peu dans la langue
française on sait jamais vraiment mais
la France d'ailleurs on sait jamais quel
est son destin
à la fois la Déclaration des droits de
l'homme et
est-ce que c'est ce fondre dans l'Europe
se fondre dans le bon sens
vous dire que l'histoire l'histoire de
la France elle est elle est faite de
contraire de paradoxe
énormément je trouve le français très
paradoxal mais vraiment oui
les catholique les protestants
les conservateurs et les Jacobins il y a
les et puis il y a aussi
c'est quand même un terroir un pays qui
aime l'autorité qui déteste les lois on
est quand même le seul pays au monde où
on vous avertit qu'il y a des flics ou
des radars en sens inverse ça c'est
génial on veut de l'ordre mais on fait
tout pour le contester
si on se fait taper sur la gueule on se
tait mais en revanche si on peut
détourner la loi alors là vraiment on y
va franco tout à l'heure vous avez parlé
de créole il y a un homme politique qui
s'appelle Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui dit
qu'il y a c'est inéluctable il y a une
créolisation de la France qui qui nous
attend et qui est en marche c'est vrai
c'est parce que ça veut dire je ne
comprends pas ce qu'on prenais pas ça
non je pense que la France est faite de
de évidemment de métissage évidemment de
de oui de variété pour moi la France
elle est variée elle est d'abord on est
non mais déjà sur ce territoire qui est
pas si grand on a la plus grande variété
de paysages au monde non mais concentré
quand même dans un dans un territoire
qui passe si grand et la France procède
de ces paysages évidemment mais oui et
de ces de ces métissages et de
moi je suis moitié russe
il y a du
je trouve qu'on est riche de ça mais
vraiment riche de ça en fait c'est une
histoire d'intégration la France qui
intègre alors oui même si
on a ce but ce goal idéal d'intégration
qui marche pas très bien il marche moins
bien aujourd'hui que par le passé je
crois qu'il a jamais tellement bien
marché mais au moins on n'a pas ce truc
anglo-saxon de dire nous on juxtapose on
y croit pas du tout à votre truc
d'intégration juxtapose
mais cela dit les Anglo-Saxons quand je
vois en Angleterre les
Indiens
sont beaucoup mieux intégrés que
le son je trouve les maghrébins ou les
ou les Noirs
d'Afrique noire ou d'ailleurs de en
France c'est à dire que il y a ce truc
anglais anglo-saxons très honnête qui
dit non prétend pas
mais les élites regardez la chancelier
d'échiquier est indien leur mère le
maire de Londres est indien
on a des progrès à faire là donc nous
avec notre idéal notre idéal pour
l'instant on court toujours après est-ce
qu'on est un pays conservateur ou à
payer révolutionnaire on est les deux on
est conservateur et très aussi ça fait
pas Jacobins que révolutionnaire mais ça
donne du c'est à dire ça donne
c'est à dire très très centralisé et
très Jacobins on aime le centre de la
culture du chef on a la culture du chef
on a la culture aussi de pas la tête qui
dépasse on est très jaloux du voisin
s'il a une R20 alors que nous on est R19
ça passe par la délation quand même
aussi on a un pays de des morts ça veut
dire qu'on place l'égalité au-dessus de
la liberté
je sais pas moi non mais j'ai
l'impression que certains oui mais
et puis il faut toujours on est quand
même un des pays qui redistribue le plus
avec quand même
on a par exemple on sort de 2 ans de
pandémie quand même le quoi qu'il en
coûte mais nos voisins européens ils
hallucides là je parlais avec une amie
espagnole qui vous êtes des enfants
gâtés ou quoi vous eux ils n'ont pas pu
le faire ça mais non au prix d'un
endettement qui est colossal mais qu'on
a les moyens de se permettre
ça veut dire que la France est généreuse
mais ça veut dire que la France elle
tourne autour de son état aussi oui mais
mine de rien heureusement qu'il est là
l'État providence et moi je l'aime
beaucoup c'était ta Providence moi je
paye mes impôts avec bonheur
mais vraiment je trouve ça génial mais
pour rien au monde on m'enlève ça mais
pour rien au monde on enlève ça à
condition que l'hôpital soit pas non
plus en crise tout le temps et que les
médecins ne partent pas pour l'instant
ils partent pas mais
non moi j'adore j'adore
l'État-providence j'adore ça et
j'en veux beaucoup aux expats qui
critiquent et qui en même temps
reviennent pour se faire soigner leur
cancer pour 218 euros 50 alors vous avez
dit à peu près qu'elle était l'idée que
vous faisiez de la France je vous
inviter à écouter quelqu'un qui a une
certaine idée d'affranche lui aussi qui
s'appelle le général de Gaulle oui donc
c'est
j'ai toujours eu une certaine idée de la
France c'est le début des de guerre du
général mais c'est aussi entre les deux
tours de l'élection présidentielle de
1965 alors qu'il est en ballotage ce qui
était pas prévu du tout il prend la
parole à la télévision et il répond à
Michel Droit qui lui dit monsieur le
Président les Français sont pas très
contents de vous parce que vous parlez
beaucoup de la France mais pas beaucoup
d'eux et voilà ce qui répond
je me fais en effet de la France une
certaine idée
je veux dire par là qu'à mon sens elle
est quelque chose
de très grand de très particulier
c'est du reste je le pense ressenti par
le monde entier
c'est vrai la France est une chose
à mes yeux
très considérable très valable et
elle doit avoir dans le monde quel qu'il
soit tout époque naturellement d'après
les circonstances elle doit avoir un
rôle à elle il faut que la France joue
son rôle c'est exact et pour qu'elle
joue son rôle il faut qu'elle soit à la
France
les Français les Français ceux qui font
la France
c'est eux qui en sont responsables la
France est plus que les français du
moment
la France vient de loin
il attrape non on sait jamais si il
parle de la France ou de lui d'ailleurs
mais il parle souvent de lui mais elle
vient de loin elle vient
ah oui oui elle vient de loin elle est
elle est animée par
elle est animée par une
force préhistorique
[Musique]
moi je le sens je vois il y a un très
joli exemple château de comarc en
Dordogne on voit où on voit ce château
qui a été qui a commencé à être érigé au
13e siècle jusqu'au début 17e 1603 et et
il est sur une falaise et puis sous la
falaise on voit les restes des des
peuplats de 9e dixième siècle au moment
des invasions vikings et avant ça on
voit et ça va jusqu'à l'époque
magdalinienne où il y a ce cheval
sublime dans la roche et ça ça symbolise
la France pour vous c'est oui en plus
c'est une cause seigneurie c'est très
intéressant c'est plus original que
juste le château fort
je le sens autant là que je le sens dans
un tableau de sésame qui va aller
chercher le le feu sous la roche de la
montagne Sainte-Victoire comme je le
sens
justement j'ai apporté un texte chez
Proust
proustillodie très il le dit beaucoup
mieux que moi il parle un moment de
Françoise ça ça gouvernante c'est dans
la recherche c'est dans le temps
retrouver je la vis peut du reste
pendant ces quelques jours car elle
allait beaucoup chez ses cousins dont
maman m'avait dit un jour mais tu sais
ils sont plus riches que toi or on avait
vu cette chose si belle qui fut si
fréquente à cette époque là dans tout le
pays et qui témoignerait s'il y avait un
historien pour un perpétuer le souvenir
de la grandeur de la France de sa
grandeur d'âme de sa grandeur selon
saint-andré-des-champs et que ne
révélèrent pas moins tant de civils
survivant à l'arrière que les soldats
tombaient à la Marne un neveu de
Françoise avait été tué à Berry-au-Bac
qui était aussi le neveu de ses cousins
millionnaires de Françoise ancien
cafetier retiré depuis longtemps après
fortune fête il avait été tué lui tout
petit cafetier sans fortune qui a la
âgée de 25 ans avait laissé sa jeune
femme seule pour tenir le petit bar
qu'il croyait regagner quelques mois
après il avait été tué
et alors on avait vu ceci
les cousins millionnaires de Françoise
et qui n'était rien à la jeune femme
veuve de leur neveu avec quitté la
campagne où ils étaient retirés depuis
10 ans et c'était remis cafetier sans
vouloir toucher un sous tous les matins
à 6h la femme millionnaire une vraie
dame était habillée ainsi que sa
demoiselle prête à aider leur nièce et
cousines par alliance et depuis plus de
trois ans elle rinçait ainsi des vers et
servait des consommations depuis le
matin jusqu'à 9h30 du soir sans un jour
de repos
dans ce livre où il n'y a pas un seul
fait qui ne soit fictif et où il n'y a
pas un seul personnage à clé où tout a
été inventé par moi selon les besoins de
ma démonstration je dois dire à la
louange de mon pays que seuls les
parents millionnaires de Françoise ayant
quitté leur retraite pour aider leur
nièce sans appui que seul cela sont des
gens réels qui existent
et persuadé que leur modestie ne s'en
offancera pas pour la raison qu'il ne
liront jamais ce livre c'est avec un
enfantin plaisir et une profonde émotion
que ne pouvant citer les noms de tant
d'autres qui durent d'agir de même et
par qui la France a survécu je transcris
ici leur nom véritable il s'appelle d'un
nom si français d'ailleurs la rivière
s'il y a eu quelques vilains en Busquets
comme l'impériieu jeune homme en smoking
que j'avais vu chez Jupien et dont la
seule préoccupation était de savoir s'il
pourrait avoir Léon à 10h30 parce qu'il
déjeunait en ville ils sont rachetés par
la foule innombrable de tous les
Français de saint-andré-des-champs par
tous les soldats sublimes auxquels
j'égale les la rivière
magnifique texte magnifiquement lu
Guillaume Gallienne il y a le troisième
mot de notre devise républicaine qui est
là la fraternité ça veut dire quelque
chose dans notre pays ah oui ah oui oui
et encore aujourd'hui
ah oui il y a
il y a rire fraternel chez les Français
que j'aime beaucoup
qui peut être assez méchant avec qui est
drôle
il y a une façon de il y a une façon à
la fois une façon franche une façon de
se serrer la main je me souviens mon
père me disant à propos d'un type il
sera jamais élu il s'est passé à une
main
mais il y a cette chose comme ça
très frange et avec une forme de pudeur
il y a une autre chose en Périgord que
j'adore quand vous entrez dans une ferme
le le fermier sort de la cuisine reste
sur le reste sur le pas de la porte la
conversation s'engage là et au bout d'un
moment au bout d'un moment assez long
il vous dira finissez d’entrer et là
c'est pour aller prendre l'apéro dans la
cuisine mais finissez d'entrer voilà
mais d'abord
chacun à sa place
et est-ce que l'Europe qui est si
critiquée tout le temps mais
elle est attaquée effectivement mais
elle est aussi critiquée en dans notre
pays par des forces politiques qui
disent l'Europe c'est elle qui a tué
finalement enfin ou qui tue la
singularité française oui bien sûr
c'était tellement mieux avant voilà
alors justement oui qui est très à la
mode aujourd'hui vous le condamnez vous
vous allez complètement ça vous énerve
ça vous énerve
c'est c'est un truc de c'est c'est un
argument de fachos
ça s'appelle ça s'appelle être en facho
enfin dire c'était mieux avant pour moi
c'est non non mais non la nostalgie
c'est pas votre truc
c'est que ça veut dire quoi c'est comme
ça me fait penser à des spectateurs de
la collie française qui dit oui mais
c'est mieux quand même en costume
commencer en costume à vous dire que
Molière c'est forcément avec déjà beau
et des dentelles vous savez le génie de
Molière traverse les siècles parce que
justement on peut encore l'adapter à
aujourd'hui on peut enfin on n'est pas
là pour filer le géologie il est de tous
les temps on n'est pas là pour faire de
la musique ça va
donc non le c'était mieux avant c'est
pas votre affaire pas du tout mais non
je trouve que on progresse énormément de
nos sociétés le mariage pour tous enfin
et donc le la France est foutue et tout
ce sont des discours que qui vous
paraissent complètement hors sujet et
pas du tout mais on a vraiment collé à
l'actualité non mais on a des problèmes
d'accord mais franchement non on est
loin d'être foutu
notre pays se porte tellement
la vibration du pays vous êtes optimiste
ah mais moi oui mais oui c'est l'amour
de votre pays après il y a des choses
qui m'énervent je trouve que parfois
vous parlez de l'État c'est vrai que
l'État prend beaucoup d'importance
[Musique]
j'aime l'État-providence j'aime plein de
choses mais par exemple regarder la rue
Molière et toute petite la rue Richelieu
est énorme
je trouvais pas ça aberrant vous auriez
préféré que ça soit le contraire même
bah oui ça va les hommes d'État très
bien mais je veux dire la bibliothèque
elle s'appelle François Mitterrand et
l'autre Richelieu il y a pas Molière
a fait beaucoup plus de bien à ce pays
que Richelieu ou Mitterrand est-ce que
vous artiste comédien est-ce que vous
avez une âme de militants est-ce que
justement en France
d'une manière privée parce que
malheureusement aujourd'hui avec les
réseaux sociaux les haters les machins
dès que vous prenez position vous en
prenez plein la gueule c'est très
violent c'est quoi ça peut être
courageux aussi parce que vous avez eu
des artistes des comédiens qui ont pris
position
de courage il sera question de courage
il faut aller sous le drapeau mais mais
sinon là qu'est-ce que vous voulez que
ma parole que ce que ça change au
contraire en plus ça je trouve souvent
ça dessert les causes parce qu'on dit à
l'autre nanti là alors du coup c'est
encore pire donc non mais c'est vrai moi
je pue le bourgeois 200 mètres mais vous
pourriez dire par exemple il nous faut
une place Molière il nous faut un
boulevard Molière
en tout cas pas au Panthéon Panthéon
c'est la République donc c'est pour
débat
j'aime beaucoup la République je suis
très attaché à la République mais la
République est la et la monarchie ça
peut parler ensemble ben non non non
suivi mais le Panthéon c'est c'est ceux
qui ont servi la République donc Molière
il peut pas être Panthéon je suis désolé
c'est comme ça ou bien non c'est
impossible bah on a qu'à créer un autre
temple des grands hommes ou des grandes
femmes surtout mais mais mais faisons-le
ailleurs mais le Panthéon en
l'occurrence c'est pour la République
c'est comme ça mais mais une grande
avenue Molière oui ou la bibliothèque
Molière peut signeriez une pétition pour
ça oui mais
vous savez mon intelligence elle ne
fonctionne que au service des auteurs
c'est là où je suis bon la mienne
individuellement franchement je parle
pas si bien j'en fais des tonnes c'est
pas très intéressant
réellement
je suis beaucoup mieux en lisant Proust
que quand je parle moins vous le voyez
non
moi je trouve que si mais je je
peux parfois voilà
je suis mieux au service des auteurs
alors on parlait de l'État il y a la
culture vous êtes un homme de culture
l'État et c'est vrai qu'en France on est
un pays aussi où l'État se mêle beaucoup
de cultures beaucoup plus que dans les
pays anglo-saxons quel sens on a bah oui
vous voyez donc et par exemple
française est une institution qui fait
d'ailleurs rayonner Molière dans le
monde d'ailleurs alors là dans ces
moments-là pardon je m'inscris il faut
dites l'état là en l'occurrence c'est le
contribuable oui c'est pas la même chose
d'accord c'est pas la même chose c'est
l'État qui nomme la rue de Richelieu et
qui fait une rue Molière toute petite en
revanche c'est le contribuable qui
finance la culture c'est l'État qui
décide que ça n'est que 1% et encore
mais mais
c'est le contribuable qui rate d'accord
ça c'est très important et on le dit
trop peu en France vous êtes fier de
votre pays très est-ce que vous jouez
quand vous jouez vous jouez à l'étranger
j'imagine ça vous est arrivé bien sûr
est-ce que vous vous sentez justement
porteur de cette culture
ambassadeur d'une certaine façon de se
en tout cas je pense à arlettique avait
dit qui avait dit à la à la jeune espoir
la première cérémonie des César par
téléphone Brialy lui dire l'éthique
est-ce que quels conseils donneriez-vous
à cette jeune comédienne je crois que
c'était Sophie Marceau et elle avait dit
de la tenue en toute circonstance
et voilà je pense ça oui je pense à la
tenue la tenue oui
est-ce que c'est un grand pays une
grande nation
parce qu'il y a de quoi être fier
vraiment pourquoi
bah notre histoire notre culture notre
langue notre poésie
[Musique]
notre liberté nos terrasses nos
notre art de vivre notre bouffe n'a
notre devise égalité fraternité notre
République
notre
charme on a beaucoup de charme parce
qu'on est imparfait
on a on est imparfait on ne cherche pas
la perfection on n'a pas le doigt sur la
couture du pantalon
ah oui je trouve que les Français ont du
charme alors vous avez lu un texte de
Proust magnifique d'ailleurs
sur en fait le sentiment national aussi
sur la France alors si c'était un
paysage par exemple varié varié ah ouais
c'est ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
au début c'est à dire que c'est un
paysage la France
la Camargue la Mer de Sable les les
poils d'air c'est une richesse la vallée
de la Dordogne la Savoie enfin c'est
dingue vous tournez beaucoup justement
si c'était un auteur un écrivain
Leila son œuvre j'aime j'aime
son engagement pour la Francophonie pour
les femmes au Maroc mais aussi j'aime
j'aime ce qu'elle tisse c'est une
tisseuse c'est une tisseuse on voit son
métier à tisser et on la voit et elle
continue son oeuvre elle tisse quelque
chose
oui si c'était un personnage historique
un personnage historique
Marie Curie alors Marie Curie une femme
aussi encore prix Nobel aussi d'ailleurs
au Panthéon oui donc encore une immigré
ouais
deux fois après Nobel deux fois prix
Nobel avec son mari
et il a fallu qu'elle puisse des coups
pour que on la reconnaisse comme ça
mais dingue non moi ça me bouleverse
même plus de l'engagement à ce niveau là
c'est du sacerdoce total mais
vous savez monsieur russe orthodoxe
tout le principe est dans l'icône c'est
à dire que l'icône c'est du c'est du
français qu'on rajoute c'est du clair
qu'on rajoute sur du fond il y a pas de
perspective il y a pas de mystère dans
l'image ce qui mystérieux c'est entre
vous et l'image c'est à dire qu'il y a
pas de mystère en Dieu Dieu existe que
vous y croyez ou pas ce qui est
mystérieux c'est la foi
Marie Curie c'est quand même ça c'est de
la foi absolue ça c'est du mystère vous
vous l'avez de la foi ah oui
si c'était une toile
Van Gogh c'est un autre erreur Van Gogh
un autre un autre étranger à notre
migrer exactement et ben ouais Van Gogh
parce que il y a la fois ouvert sur Waze
et la Provence parce que parce que
il peint la France
extraordinairement bien
derrière petite question quel est
l'auteur français que vous préférez
jouer
si la question est pertinente
bah Molière reste génial du théâtre
c'est un
c'est tellement écrit par un acteur et
en plus il
va tellement raconté l'humanité
au devant de toute démonstration
possible c'est pas son propos
il va parler en plus de l'intime de la
famille
avec des relations quand même
compliquées et
ça peut pas se réduire à l'humeur et
pourtant c'est aussi fait d'humeur voire
de mauvaises humeur il va aller chercher
tous les défauts français il y a du
Louis de Funès ou du
il y a cette espèce de
cette fascination qu'on a pour nos
défauts Louis de Funès c'est quand même
ça je veux dire son génie c'est de jouer
bon très vite mais
au-delà de sa rapidité c'est qu'il va
aller chercher tous les tous les tous
les défauts français la mauvaise foi la
muflerie la lâcheté là il va toujours
du jardin ça aussi aujourd'hui jardin
c'est très très bien jouer les défauts
français et ça donne un charme
et la drôlerie
qui est propre à la France ah oui je
trouve
on n'a pas l'humour en clair on n'a pas
ce
Gaulois chez nous je retiens ce mot le
charme ouais ah oui je crois qu'on a
vraiment beaucoup de charme merci
beaucoup merci
[Musique]